more dumplings our future don't import
dangerous
[Music]
[Laughter]
this [__] THC grease in the back of
the Ain't Nothing sec TKO [__] 200
milligrams taking a leak to the hoop
please about to eat one we're gonna
split one that's it
it's gonna be a mound Monday night here
in the often sticky-wicky
this is the [__] right here he's just
smelling getting sickly sia
the guy told me when i wanted he called
me play he's like a special special
greasy mother [__] this week there you
go you like me now [__] happy
Halloween boom I don't give a [__] about
Halloween Halloween is over if you're 12
and you got a propeller on your helmet
then happy Halloween deal the rest is go
[__] yourselves Uncle Joe here Monday
October 31st the beautiful thing is you
are here we got some beautiful Reaper
tonight some hardcore which is hardcore
that's a [__] Skywalker always
from perennial supply me the strongest
best reefer for my [__] mental state
right now was a great weekend in Las
Vegas thank you for coming out for the
shows if you came out my man talking lay
always represented there's my man look
at them kobracast go take a quick cash
look at them it's time for some many
bong hits tonight it's early still I'll
wait put some ice in the [__] bombs
and let's get this [__] party started
it's an uncle joey's miss you I miss you
sometimes I miss you [__] from
the bottom of my heart I really do I
just ain't got time to be smoking dope
all day which you said quick [__] the
movement sometimes I don't have time to
give you a five-minute warning set it up
you know I don't have the
I got a smoke on a [__] run here are
you [__] kidding me or what
that's a Halloween smoke right there I
left the roach one of the little kids
today hopefully you'll find it we always
gotta leave a roach on Halloween for
these little [__] see what the
[__] they pump into oh [__] look at Lisa
at going deep into the murk on him out
of his nose early on the color of his
face it matches the kobracast shirt
machine what have you done with your
life [__] huh just kick him back
house of the holy huncle Joey Lisa Ann
no big deal there's no celebrities here
there's nobody the campus is nobody
hugging now that [__] here I don't
know what the [__] my pockets
[Music]
bond water on my shirt I don't give a
[__] anymore that's how we're cooking it
tonight this is the rule made of smoke
that's what I have for Halloween the
smoke the smoke of the ghost you can't
walk on one [__] leg and I'm saying
tomorrow lost souls day oh [__]
Wednesday All Saints Day that's right
[__] is a big month
I shoot must I shoot somebody
[Music]
that's what I'd [__] do forget juice
I hate this weekend
[Music]
you go told you trade training pays
little people whoever says your training
babe that's why do you army doesn't we
got a train [__] every day two
three bond it's extended Brett's doctor
beliefs you don't see my shoulders going
up and down dear it's all in your
[__] right there that's where the
weed is right in your stomach right
there and it sends all the nerve endings
next thing you know you're [__]
hungry you eat up on the [__] salami
my shirt smells like bong water but ask
me if I give a [__] I don't give a [__]
people don't hug me oh I just cut a
little [__] fight there we'll have a
need a lot today for those [__] days
I took a four we beaten and that's it
[Music]
start this podcast in a few minutes just
wait to the [__] Haunter
there's one of my favorite album sides
of all time houses of the Holy
Led Zeppelin side one dancing days no
court of the ocean
no Magica don't get much better than
that people the elbow is good tonight
these are strong [__] dummies when
they're fresh they're really [__]
delicious you understand me well these
things are fresh the bonds are strong
tonight everything it's Monday
[__] they supposed to be strong
Mondays today right you're stronger all
the powers around you your senses well
at least that's what you strive for us
so we could pull a quick one over
[Music]
are you guys going at home okay
everything all right you raid
grandmother's [__] medicine cabinet
yeah there's gotta be something good man
boy I am [__] Haile was right that
bomb was very good time well guess what
it's time for more fathers we'll put
this guy walk away and we'll break up
this other [__] I got here oh [__]
[Music]
break up the Chinese heroin tonight's
the night you might stab your
grandmother asleep tonight your face
Chinese heroin soon it's on its way
Ming Mouse team
[Music]
do tell me ya know and like I almost I
understand the people who like that guy
who shot the guy who's talking I get
pissed off what are they talking about
people talking about the movie dancer
it's always couples and they just they
go back and forth and I don't want to
sometimes that move were you closely six
seeds away because it was one of the
ones where you pick your seats an old
saying that when I picked it but it's a
next one up and we're probably have
little tiny seeds so don't have that
many seats in the theater but I went in
the back where there wasn't anybody
these guys came in after I came in guys
or girls really drinking in there trying
to be cute well no I always those new
Gentiles and I [__] hate they're like
that they're Mexican person
they were Mexican trying to be white I
love shooting them when they're Mexican
they're trying to be white and [__]
nobody smack them in the [__] face
real hard they said get it together
[__]
close the door
somebody's coming home to now look at
all that weed [__] you don't
ask you [__] to kill [__] Michael the
Archangel no just looking like what the
[__] are you talking about bagel this is
what killed Michael the Archangel
[__] right yeah you people thought this
party was over this party's just getting
started
training [__] Monday night oh that's
the one right there that's the one right
there
[Music]
- true
I'll make the Japanese got Betty - hmm a
piece of my lung just came out but I
swallow it [__] so get you know mend
on the inside I'm saying I'm happy
people having a good time we uncle Joey
try just [__] around here doing
Barnett's listen to music it doesn't get
no feminist no drama no celebrities no
faint people just me and my GU mob love
Lisa
[Music]
oh [__] what time is it Tarzan it will
see you [__] in ten minutes
stay black stay beautiful YouTube /
YouTube slap calm that / Jesus Joey Diaz
around I see you [__] Palin stay
black